[Music]
I want to live
not nearly survived
and I won't give up this dream of life
that keeps me alive I gotta be me I
gotta be me what else can I be
[Music]
I'll go it alone
how it must be
be right for somebody else if I'm not
right for me daring to tries that series
Verdi
[Music]
I
you
[Music]
hey everybody is Charlie let's break
down this Westworld season 2 trailer
from Comic Con surprisingly they'd only
been filming for a week so all of the
new footage in this is literally from
that first episode they might cut some
of it out like it doesn't always make it
to air but there were just a couple
things from Comic Cons and I didn't have
time to get through because it all
dumped at the same time so much awesome
stuff so if you didn't pick up on it I
want to live the song that they use in
this is a cover of a John Denver song so
it's all about the host slowly becoming
aware like they've achieved the maze or
they're in the process of traveling the
bays people like to Laura's people like
Bernard that look like they're just
slowly taking everything in Delores
actually looks like she's actively
running down guests in shooting them but
she's not quite that vicious even though
Ford took advantage of her programming
override at her commands and set them on
the path to journey in tonight that's
the title of season 2 it's also the
title of his new narrative but you know
in a metaphorical way he's sort of
setting the host on the path to
independence taking control of their own
destiny so it's sort of like the park is
journeying into night it's kind of in
its death throes that's why you see the
parks slowly eating itself alive all the
hosts going absolutely apeshit and then
you have that player piano which was the
metaphor for their programming it would
reset every day every day it would start
playing the same song everybody's
memories would reset in a new batch of
guests would come in but now you sort of
see the man in black smile really big
with all the blood on his face as the
player piano stops like it's the first
indication that all the hosts now are
starting to move forward but the idea is
is that this wasn't happening to
everyone all at the same time so
characters like Dolores Barnard are just
the tip of the spear as the other host
slowly awaken to consciousness in the
whole idea the first season the
bicameral mind was is that you know
ancient cultures thought that one
hemisphere of the brain talking to the
other was really like God speaking to
you but in the world of the show people
thought of Arnold as God speaking to the
host through some ethereal means like
maybe he was part of the digital
programming somehow he achieved some
sort of immortality but then we learned
that the secret was is that the hosts
were actually talking to themselves
that's what the reveries were all about
they were able to access their own
memory so it was almost like their past
selves were speaking to them reminding
them of all these things that they've
been through and it was bootstrapping
their consciousness that's why you would
see Delores keep coming back to that
town over and over the first time we see
her in that town she sort of flashes
back so you have the original version of
Delores in this outfit from when they
first opened the park then you have the
flashback version of Delores with
William then you have Delores in present
day against the man in black the old man
version of William so Delores realizes
that she's come on this journey and
found the center of the maze many times
in the past but they keep resetting her
memory
so journey and tonight is Ford trying to
break that cycle so that they can
continue to move forward in the idea is
that you have all these other parts we
saw a glimpse of samurai world when
they've learned her daughter was in
another part that was numbered
differently we're like oh my god if this
is a different number how many other
parks are there this is Lawrence here
hanging upside down if you can't see
it's kind of blurry so he survives most
of the main cast is coming back they
made it sound like Anthony Hopkins is
not coming back and we don't know if
young William is going to come back
either it sounds like he might not Jimmy
Simpson was like I feel like his story
is done but you never know so I'm not
expecting Ben Barnes to come back either
as Logan but we might get an old man
version of Logan in present-day we don't
really know what his status is but the
way Williams sent him off naked on that
horse made it sound like he just wanted
his father who truly controlled the
delos corporation to put William his
son-in-law in power instead of Logan his
natural-born son because he was too
crazy and Logan is known for doing crazy
things so it didn't seem like too big of
a stretch we also know that there were
all those board members that were
massacred during the journey in
tonight's sequence that Ford initiated
they probably didn't get everybody Tessa
Thompson might still be around so I'm
expecting her to crawl back in season
two but there were a whole lot of red
shirts in that crowd so for the most
part most of the main cast is coming
back there were just a couple plot lines
that they didn't resolve by the end of
the series and it was the secret plan
that the board was using
the park for like they didn't care about
the host they didn't care about the
narratives they had another interest in
the park and I think that had to do with
the idea of achieving a version of
immortality but we'll see that in season
two because if they didn't care about
the host doing what the hosts were
designed to do then what is their value
to them if they can't sell a version of
immortality transplanting your
consciousness into another host which is
a big sci-fi idea but we'll see because
it sounds like the delos corporation has
unlimited money so they're not looking
to make more money than what is it that
they really want with these parks but as
far as we know they could bring forward
back and in that serial way like the way
that we found out that he was secretly
masquerading as Arnold this whole time
but it wasn't a digital version of Ford
it was the real fort that was just
reprogramming things on the fly any time
the show talked about Arnold changing
code like they did this big
investigation where they're like
somebody named Arnold do you know who
that is
that was secretly Ford trying to honor
his dead partners wishes and help the
hosts achieve true consciousness like he
had a change of heart after Arnold died
and says it's a really long game into
motion to help the hosts out well let me
know in the comments the hosts look like
they've completely won just burning
everything to the ground in Westworld
what do you want them to do with season
two aside from visit some of the other
parks because it's not going to be so
simple as them just going and doing the
same thing in another park this was sort
of happening all over the place but
we're just experiencing it through the
Dolores character so they're just
implying that this is going to be
happening to all of the hosts eventually
but like I said they've been shooting
for a couple weeks now because Comic Con
has been over for about a week they'll
probably try and get it out during the
spring so remember how Kamath Rose used
to premiere in April in previous years
they'll probably try and get Westworld
season two out around that time maybe by
early summer just depends on how long it
takes them to finish the episodes
there'll be ten episodes in season two
so they'll probably some more promos
later this year but what will happen is
is I have a couple more comic-con videos
to get through there's a bunch of
Avengers Secret Invasion Captain Marvel
Scrolls all kinds of stuff to get
through before new Game of Thrones drops
on Sunday so they've all your requests
in the comments below be sure to
subscribe to get everything
why you
paper that you can click here for the
trailer for the next game of Thrones and
you can click here for all my West world
videos thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight